good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it was supposed to be
the most cheerful holiday season
imaginable for the democratic party
for three years they fantasized about
impeaching donald trump
lurid visions of trials convictions the
helicopter lifting off from the last
time from the white house
lawn to sustained applause from the
press corps here in washington
big orange gone forever banished to
mar-a-lago
the left-back in power order restored
it'd be like the 2016 election never
even happened
it was all a bad dream that's the
democrats thought they were getting for
christmas this year
unfortunately for them santa got delayed
they're not getting a pony this year
they're getting a bag of hair instead of
destroying trump impeachment appears to
have made him even stronger like
godzilla
it turns out that parading bureaucrats
before the cameras to demand
that you send money to ukraine shut up
no questions allowed
isn't very effective as a campaign
strategy
and as a result support for impeachment
has fallen
even among core democratic voters
here's the latest example an emerson
poll released last week found that among
african-american voters for example
just 37 now support impeachment 38
are opposed while 25 were uncertain
which itself is significant
meanwhile in the same poll among white
voters 44 supported impeachment
that's not among white democrats it's
among all white voters so think about
that for a second
that means african americans though they
remain the most loyal democratic
constituency
tend to be more skeptical of impeachment
in other words in the democratic party
it is white liberals who are howling for
impeachment
the rest of the party not so much
that's interesting and unexpected and it
has democratic leaders squirming
they promised their base impeachment the
press told them it was a sure thing
it's hard to back off from that but
going forward could devastate the party
next fall
new polls from rasmus and emerson both
show the president's approval rating
rising if donald trump could get even
half the figure among black voters that
he's getting now in those polls he will
win
re-election that has cnn commentator
anna navarro on edge when she saw that
poll
she tweeted this quote zero chance this
is accurate zero
the poll must have been conducted in the
homes of ben carson kanye
that sheriff guy with the hat and those
two cubic zirconia and polyester spandex
ladies
in other words it's a lot like her
party's reaction to 2016. keep talking
and pretend it never happened